THINK WE CAN ALL UNDERSTAND HIS
ANGER AND TRANSLATE THE BLEEP.
JOINING ME NOW IS LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK WHO WAS
GRABBING THE MICROPHONE TO SPEAK
WHEN MR. O'ROURKE HAD THIS
OUTBURST.
DAN, FIRST OF ALL, OUR DEEPEST
PRAYERS AND CONDOLENCE TOSS
EVERYONE IN TEXAS AND THE PEOPLE
OF UVALDE WHO ARE SUFFERING SO
GREATLY TONIGHT.
WE HAVE TO SAY THAT BEFORE WE
SAY ANYTHING ELSE.
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY AT THAT
PRESS CONFERENCE?
>> SO LAURA.
>> Laura: SO DESPICABLE.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE TELL US
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> YES.
SO WHEN I SAT DOWN, I NOTICED
THAT -- WE WERE IN THE LARGE
AUDITORIUM IN THE HIGH SCHOOL I
NOTICED THAT BETO WAS ON THE END
AND I LITERALLY COULD SEE HIM
LEANING FORWARD ALMOST LIKE HE
WAS GETTING READY TO POUNCE.
BUT I DIDN'T IMAGINE -- I DO SEE
MAYBE HE WAS GOING TO STAND UP
AND ASK A QUESTION AT SOME POINT
OR MAKE A STATEMENT.
BUT I COULD NEVER IMAGINE THAT
ON THIS DAY, WHEN WE WERE THERE
TO NOT ONLY DISSEMINATE
INFORMATION AND LEARN MORE, BUT
WERE THERE TO BE WITH THESE
FAMILIES, THAT HE WOULD PULL
SUCH A POLITICAL STUNT.
YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT LAURA, AND I
SAID IN MY COMMENTS AFTER HE
FINALLY LEFT, THAT CAN'T WE HAVE
JUST ONE DAY?
ONE WEEK, ONE MONTH, OF US ALL
COMING TOGETHER FOR THESE
CHILDREN?
NOT A POLITICAL STUNT?
NOT PART SANE POLITICS?
WHERE'S OUR HUMANITY.
AND WHAT WE FOUND OUT IS BETO
O'ROURKE IS MORE INTERESTED IN
HIS POLITICAL AMBITIONS THAN HE
WAS ABOUT THESE FAMILIES AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY WHAT WAS THE
TRAGEDY OF HIS BEHAVIOR.
IT SHOWED HE REALLY DIDN'T CARE
ABOUT THESE PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE WERE THERE
FOR, GOVERNOR ABBOTT SAID,
MYSELF AND THE OTHERS WHO SPOKE.
>> Laura: HE CERTAINLY COULDN'T
HAVE THOUGHT, DAN, THAT WHAT HE
EVERS DOING WAS BRINGING COMFORT
TO THE FAMILIES OR REALLY
NOTHING WAS GOING TO ADVANCE THE
NARRATIVE OF SAFETY OR CONCERN.
THIS WAS FIRST AND FOREMOST AN
ACT OF POLITICAL SELFISHNESS.
PERIOD.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY, AND WELL PLANNED BY
THE WAY.
HE CAME -- AGAIN I SAW HIM OUT
OF THE CORNER OF MY EYE AND I
WAS WONDERING WHAT HE WAS UP TO.
HE HAD A RIGHT TO BE THERE.
BUT TOTAL POLITICAL SELFISHNESS.
AND SO HERE WE ARE LAURA, AND
THIS IS NOT, BY THE WAY, WHAT
TEXANS EXPECT IN A LEADER TO
BEHAVE LIKE THIS, PARTICULARLY
IN THIS STATE.
HE COULD HAVE HAD A PRESS
CONFERENCE OUTSIDE IF HE WANTED,
OR BROUGHT THIS UP AT SOME OTHER
TIME.
BUT NOT THIS DAY.
IT WAS JUST OFFENSIVE TO THESE
CHILDREN WHO DIED AND THESE
TEACHERS.
AND BY THE WAY, LAURA, I FOUND
OUT IN TALKING TO ONE OF THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES, ONE OF THE
TEACHERS WHO WAS KILLED WAS
FOUND DEAD LAYING ON TOP OF A
STUDENT.
AS I SAID YESTERDAY WHEN I WAS
INTERVIEWED, WE WOULD HEAR
STORIES ABOUT THESE HEROIC
TEACHERS AND THE HEROISM OF
THESE TWO TEACHERS IN THAT
CLASSROOM AND THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- LAURA, I'VE BEEN
THROUGH A LOT IN TEXAS.
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF SHOOTINGS IN
TEXAS, A LOT OF DISASTERS.
BUT WHENEVER IT'S CHILDREN, AS
YOU SAID WITH YOUR OWN, I HAVE
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN, IT
GETS TO WHO WE ARE AT THE CORE
AS A COUNTRY.
AND LAUER THAT, I JUST -- FOR
HIM TO DO THAT TODAY AND FOR US
TO EVEN SPEND FIVE MINUTES
TALKING ABOUT IT, I JUST DISMISS
HIM.
AND I THINK AMERICA AND TEXAS
DISMISSED HIM TODAY FRANKLY.
>> Laura: LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
BACK TO THE QUESTION I ASKED, IF
SOMEONE IS HELL BENT ON MAIMING
AND DESTROYING THEY WILL FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO DO IT PROBABLY
RIGHT?
WE'LL FIND OUT MORE.
BUT IF THERE WAS A SIDE ENTRANCE
OR A BACK DOOR THAT WAS OPEN,
THAT CAN'T HAPPEN AT ANY SCHOOL
IN THE COUNTRY.
IT JUST CAN'T HAPPEN.
THOSE HAVE TO BE SECURED AND A
FRONT DOOR HAS TO BE THE ONLY
POINT OF ENTRY.
WE'VE SAID THIS BEFORE AND I
THINK YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT IT BEFORE.
>> YAY WE DID.
FOUR YEARS AGO LAST WEEK WAS THE
SHOOTING AT SANTE FE AND THE DAY
OF THE SHOOTING THAT WAS THE
FIRST THING I RECOGNIZED THAT
OUR SCHOOLS ARE NOT PROTECTED
THE WAY THEY SHOULD BEMENT WE
PUT IN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY, OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TRYING TO GIVE THE
SCHOOLS THE TOOLS TO FORTIFY
THEIR SCHOOLS.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS AS SIMPLE AS YOU
SOUND, OR AS YOU SAY, PEOPLE
SAY, BUT OUR ELEMENTARY AND
MIDDLE SCHOOLS FOR SURE ARE NOT
THAT BIG WHERE WE CAN CONTROL
THE EXIT.
YOU SHOULD HAVE ONE-WAY IN,
EVERYONE ONE WAY OUT, EVERY DOOR
SHOULD BE LOCKED.
AND I WENT UP TO WHERE THAT DOOR
WAS TODAY.
I WALKED THAT AREA.
HAD THAT DOOR BEEN LOCKED AND HE
HAD TAKEN A FEW MORE MINUTES TO
LOOK FOR ANOTHER ENTRANCE, HE
MAY HAVE BEEN STOPPED BEFORE
GETTING INTO THE SCHOOL.
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WE DO
THAT.
AND OUR HIGH SCHOOLS, WE'RE EVEN
GOING TO HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE REDESIGN OUR HIGH SCHOOLS
BECAUSE OUR HIGH SCHOOLS ARE SO
LARGE LAURA THAT ONE ENTRANCE
DOESN'T WORK BUT WE'VE GOT TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
BUT, LAURA, IF I CAN, I JUST
COME BACK TO THIS, LAURA.
THIS PROBLEM IS A MUCH LARGER
PROBLEM THAN THE INFRASTRUCTURE,
THE GUN ISSUE, THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE.
THIS IS -- AND ALL THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY,
LAURA, WE ARE IN A SICK SOCIETY
WHERE WE ARE AT EACH OTHER'S
THROATS ALL THE TIME.
YOU SHOWED IT TODAY.
EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK, WE ARE
JUST, WHETHER IT'S ON THE
INTERNET, WHETHER IT'S ANY WALK
OF LIFE, PEOPLE ARE JUST AT EACH
OTHER EVERY DAY, AND WE HAVE TO
ASK OURSELF WHO WE ARE.
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE A NATION OF
GODLY PEOPLE AND GODLY PEOPLE
NEED TO PRAY.
>> Laura: YEAH, GOT TO MAKE
CHANGES.
>> WE'VE GOT TO MAKE CHANGES.
SECOND CHRONICLE 714 LAURA
EVERYONE SHOULD READ TONIGHT, GO
TO THE MIDDLE OF THE BIBLE TURN
RIGHT, CHRISTIANS HAVE TO PRAY
FOR GOD TO HEAL OUR LAND AND WE
HAVE TO TAKE A STAND.
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO ARE NOT BELIEVERS,
THAT'S FINE I RESPECT THEIR
RIGHT NOT TO BELIEVE.
BUT FOR THOSE OF US WHO ARE
CHRISTIANS WE NEED TO TAKE HOLD
OF OUR COUNTRY AND WE DO THAT
THROUGH PRAYER.
YOU DO NOT CHANGE THE CULTURE OF
A COUNTRY WITHOUT CHANGING THE
CHARACTER OF THE PEOPLE AND YOU
CAN'T CHANGE CHARACTER WITHOUT A
HEART AND YOU CAN